hey everybody welcome back to Omar City
today's episode will be the first in a
couple in which I'll be working on the
airport and this is really an episode
which I've been looking forward to for a
super long time and I've also spent a
lot of time just figuring out how I
wanted to do everything and actually
preparing this episode so I'm really
happy to finally get this out there and
be able to show off the beginnings of
the airport um it's still quite simple
in this episode I'm mostly chipping away
at the general layouts of the airport
and getting all of the public transport
in there's a little bit of detailing and
a little bit of messing with uh the the
road decals and things like that for
additional detailing which I haven't
done so far uh but which is a especially
lately really changing the game so I
wanted to mess with that a little bit as
well and experiment with making parking
lots but the focus is definitely on the
airport so without further Ado let's get
into the time lapse and see how this
thing is
built now before I went into the airport
itself I still had to figure out all of
the roads that are leading to the
airport and kind of calculate how far
away from the rest of the city it's
going to be I built a quick test of the
airport before I actually went in and
recorded the final version right here uh
so I'm trying to measure up everything
in such a way that it's actually
completely true to what I did beforehand
and um there's going to be a bit of a a
sort of sunken Highway for this section
of Road over here which sounds very
unlike Omar City and I'll definitely
talk a bit more about that when it gets
its own episode at some point in the
future which is most likely going to
happen um but that's just going to
provide a good entrance into the city
that should hopefully be free of con
gestion and also be able to actually
keep all of those cars out of the
streets hopefully and um it's also going
to be pretty much the entryway into the
airport as well so we have the um
Highway exits and the highway entrances
going to the airport hooking up to this
highway and in fact the entire airport
itself will be sort of focused around uh
an Athletics field shape road which is
kind of like a Ring Road of the airport
going around here and within that I'll
be placing all of the important
buildings parking lots of the airport
and just on the outside of that we have
the main terminal over here and the main
terminal is a sort of funky simple
design just putting together a bunch of
different terminals I was messing with
that for quite a bit trying to figure
out what I wanted to get because many of
the international terminals are quite
large and I wanted to have an airport
with only one Runway which seemed like
it was the most appropriate thing to do
given the scale of the city and uh
because of that I also wanted to go for
somewhat of a small terminal but still
one that has a very unique look I didn't
want to give like the city a terminal
that's just fresh of the workshop and
looks like anything else so um hopefully
by putting together a few different very
small Terminals and assets and also some
office blocks in the future uh we can
actually have a very Airport terminal
looking building that's still quite
unique while at the same time being
small enough to be realistic for this
City now about the runways uh or the
only Runway and the taxiways that we
have around here I mostly wanted to work
on the shaping of these of these
taxiways and put all of these small
paths around them mostly because I feel
like the in-game taxiways and runways
don't quite connect to each other as you
would see in real life like in real life
they're much more curvy around the sides
uh like this and they're also a bit
wider I do feel like that taxi ways and
I haven't really measured this up so I'm
not quite sure um but they look to be
quite a bit more narrow uh than you'd
see in real life so I wanted to make
them a little bit more thick and smooth
by putting all of the paths around them
and the reason that I chose to go for
just one Runway which might seem a
little bit weird especially given how
many of the airports that are being
built in City skylines are really just
experiments with different runways and
um making these large awesome
international airports as much as I
wanted to do something like that it just
wouldn't fit in the city it's already
quite a stretch to give the city a
Runway the basic idea behind it is that
Almar city is an airport city uh which
is very shortly put uh just an idea of a
city that heavily centers around an
airport the inspiration comes from suo
idb which is in South Korea which is a
very new uh development in um
well I think it's an Inon but it's very
close to an airport right there and it's
super new and it's a very large
experiment in City Planning as well
which is close to an airport and that's
sort of a very defining feature for it
because that that just makes you
instantly very connected with the rest
of the world uh so if you're on that
kind of service economy it's just a
great thing to have and that's the idea
that I had with alar city as well but
the only issue is that alar city is
quite small and I'm not sure if we're
even going to reach the 100,000 cap by
any
margin we're probably going to end up
pretty low beneath that uh so even
though I wanted to have an airport for
this city especially given that
otherwise it's just cut off from the
rest of the World by a lone Highway in
Bahrain because there isn't even any
road service or a real road service in
Bahrain um I did want to have that
airport but it just had to be quite
small to keep it real realistic and the
main Inspirations here were on sort of
similar airports even though they do
serve larger cities uh like London
Airport or rdam the H airport uh those
two were the biggest Inspirations uh
there's also M Aran airport which is
another one of these funky one Runway
airports and then another inspiration
which is obviously quite important is
Manama International Airport in Bahrain
itself so that just kind of gave me an
idea of what the actual airport in
Bahrain is designed like and what kind
of markings they use on the runway stuff
like that uh you might have noticed that
I'm already doing the markings on the
highway right here but that's just sort
of standard Fair anyway um but I already
did some markings on the um on the
runway as well and I wasn't quite sure
about that like this is one of the the
things where I would love to get
feedback if that's possible because I
tried to look up like the different
Runway marking that I would have to get
but it seems as though uh the Bahrain R
Runway markings are somewhat different
and um basically I've just copied the
ones that Manama airport has and I'm not
entirely sure if that's all correct but
yeah that's what I did with the runway
markings and detailing of the runway of
the airport so that's just what that is
based off and then when it comes to the
highway I just wanted to keep that you
know simple standard Highway markings I
was actually quite happy with how these
highways worked out I think uh when the
straight uh line prop tool just came out
like the same day I tried out this
design for Highway exits and entrances
um which is made by branching of a
three-lane high highway from a two-lane
Highway at 160° and uh just one square
long which is very narrow but it's
actually a very easy way to get that
smooth transition into a slip lane
pretty much instantly so that's what I
tried doing there instead of using move
it and I'm quite happy with that and the
rest of those exits and entrances to the
highway are really just putting down the
right lines with um the prop line tool
and that aside it's all just quite
simple I didn't want to really overdo
this too much as you can see a lot of
the road works for the airport are quite
simple we just have this one sort of
Athletics stet field shaped um Road
around the ring and then within that we
have all of the important services and
one of them is going to be the bus
station as well there are going to be a
couple of bus lines that I obviously
want to hook up to this airport as well
and also on this side in the middle of
the Big R uh ring for the metro station
which is also going to be quite
important we have the long-term parking
and I realized that this might look like
the the smallest long-term parking
you've ever seen I also took some
inspiration from London City airport for
this uh because there simply isn't much
to do with a car in Omar City there are
some car roads and there are definitely
some parking areas as well but with the
way that the city is designed I'm trying
to actively discourage car usage as much
as I can uh so I'm not expecting uh too
much cars coming into the airport from
Omar City especially when it's that
close and when you've got a bus
connection and a Metro connection uh so
the parking is more or less also kind of
a little bit to serve the rest of Bakin
um because if this were real the idea of
Amar city is that it's somewhere in the
south of Bahrain on the east coast of it
and there's no airport around that area
so I do figure that you know if there
realistically was one around here and if
Amar City would uh be built in real life
uh then it would kind of serve those
areas as well so there is still some
parking but I'm keeping it on quite a
small uh scale now on this side we have
the techi lane as well so we've got all
of the uh like the taxi stops I guess
where you can just wait for a taxi and
also there's going to be some short-term
parking around that area as well but
before I went into detailing that area I
wanted to go back to the long-term
parking and detail that a little bit
take a bit of a side step from the
airport and start working on the parking
areas now I have to give massive credit
to strick toaster over here for just
being the complete inspiration from uh
for this uh in Arrowhead Valley uh where
he built this amazing parking lot and
that was pretty much what I intended to
try over here as well and it's my my
first sort of uh take messing around
with this as well but I'm really happy
with it uh you can actually notice uh
that I used the wrong asphalt texture
here because frankly we do have the
pable asphalt mod which is really
amazing um but at this point I actually
didn't get that one to work and I know
in hindsight that it was because I
didn't have OverWatch inst installed so
I have that now so it is working in
hindsight um but at the time I was still
using decals and that was a pretty big
mistake I had to go back and redo all of
that U but I Spar you that in the video
so we're just going to keep the asphalt
for now like this and the idea is just
that we're filling in the entire space
with asphalt and hooking that up to an
actual Road and cars will actually be
able to drive over these roads and go to
these parking lots like the parking lots
are all parks and uh all the spaces
between the parking lots are the
concrete roads from Network extensions
and pretty much over that we have all of
the decals to get the asphalt in and
then some extra Planters and decorations
to make everything look quite neat and
we actually have some pretty good
looking parking spots and I'm just a
huge fan of this uh because it means
that we can actually have asphalt
parking lots in instead of having it on
the sidewalks as you usually see now and
uh it works especially well if you've
got like these large parking lots like
these um even though you know I am
actively trying to not build these
because this is armar City and I'm not
really an American styled uh city with a
lot of focuses on large parking lots as
you would see around shopping malls uh
areas like that in America um but over
here it's actually really fun to build
this and it's I think it's a fting
addition to the airport and a good way
to fill in this sort of oval space uh
that's in the middle of the the sort of
ring that we have going on for the
Metro so yeah I'm quite happy with how
this turned out all of the decorations
around it really do bring it to life
though that aside it's just a huge field
of asphalt and to be very Frank uh this
is this is one of the things that uh you
know I'm sort of trying to avoid with
Amar City I think these large stretches
of asphalt in the middle of your city uh
especially near downtowns having these
large parking spaces Outdoors is
something that's really ruining the
entire life of a city but you know in
this case it's right next to the airport
and it's about the best way to get some
long-term parking in I may very well
actually get some parking lots or
parking garages a little bit further
away from the airport as well as a
second long-term parking because this is
quite small
uh just in case I would like to have
that as well but that's something that's
going to have to be further away from
the airport uh because this is really as
much space as I have sitting right in
front of the
terminal now as for the detailing a lot
of this actually does come down to the
decals again like decals have just been
game changers every ever since the time
that they came out and the more that are
coming out the more you can also have
like all of these different variations
between them uh but a lot of the
detailing was also uh some foliage now
back on the topic of decals actually
what I also wanted to try here is
actually get some of the lines in for
these airplanes it's just very basic
right now and I didn't even get all of
the lines in um but I did notice that
the yellow lines that you get from the
game itself are hardly noticeable and
they don't actually like curve to follow
the paths that planes should be taking
as they should be and the yellow lines
just stop whenever there's a junction so
I really wanted to place my own to make
them a little bit more visible and also
make sure that we do actually have some
curved lines going on at the Junctions
and um then there's just a couple more
Airfield assets over here and I figured
it was time to finish up the Ring Road
going back to the other side so that uh
cars coming in from the other side of
the highway can actually hook up to the
Ring Road and enter the airport as well
now this road will also be used to kind
of serve the industry areas around the
airport too uh because we do have the
terminal of course but aside from that I
also wanted to have some hangers hangars
anyway those storage spaces for
airplanes as well um and also a small
distribution center and of course also a
fuel supply somewhere uh so I definitely
of course wanted to have uh a sort of
industrial Lots alongside the Airfield
as well so we have that going on there
and and some of the roads that are going
to be branching off from this main Ring
Road are going to service all of that
industry which I am going to inevitably
need um but before I get into that I
wanted to make sure that I also
decorated the area within the ring a
little bit more and kind of built some
offices alongside the highway because
obviously you always have that kind of
sort of uh service development offices
and such are being built around
airfields or airports I'm not sure why I
keep saying a field but you you do very
often have that kind of stuff and I
figured especially since this is really
the entrance into the city uh coming
from the rest of the country over the
highway I uh could actually have some
Highway side office bases around here
and with that this should really
hopefully be uh shaping up to be a real
airport District now um before I went on
I wanted to shape up the sort of
artificial Island um for the runway as
well because it is really jutting out
into the sea uh to make sure that it
it's close enough to the city uh while
at the same time you know not being
pointed toward the city and there's a
thing about this where I'm not entirely
sure if it's correct because I I have no
idea what's north south and east in the
game but the idea of Amar city is that
it's in the southeast of Bahrain on the
coast right there and um the prevailing
wind direction in Bahrain is also uh
toward the southeast East uh so by
having the runway over here um you
should usually be able to land uh with
less than uh like 45° difference in wind
direction which is I think what you need
if you want to uh land correctly at
least that's uh one of the reasons why
uh airports always have many different
runways going in different
directions um I know actually that's the
reason why the airport in the
Netherlands has the most stupid layout
ever which is highly practical but has
runways going everywhere because the
wind is very unpredictable in the
Netherlands but anyway um that's why the
airport or the runway is moving into
that direction so hopefully with one
Runway we should be usually more or less
okay to land planes um but also I had to
make sure that the runway was long
enough uh so that actually actually the
planes that I needed to land in this uh
airport can actually land in there
because the the in-game runway uh is
stupidly short by the way I'm just
building some Office Buildings in the
background right here because I just
wanted to finish that around the highway
but yeah the the in-game runway is super
short and um as far as all the research
that I kind of did on this topic the the
minimum Runway that a Boeing 737800
needs is 270 M which equals 260 squares
in game and that was the maximum sort of
length that I wanted to go for for the
runway like just enough so that um
Boeing 737s can land over here which
works U because that is a sort of medium
range International airplane and it's
also an airplane with a lot of assets on
the workshop so I can actually
realistically do that and a lot of the
bigger airplanes like 747s all of the
jumbo Jets pretty much um need huge
runways of like up to 3 km and more so
there was no way that I was going to be
featuring any any kind of Runway like
that it also would absolutely dwarf the
city like this this Runway being 2 km is
already showing just how small this city
actually is but yeah I went for the
length of just over 2,000 uh M for this
Runway so that we can land Boeing 737s
in here I think there's also the
bombarder uh C
rj700 uh which I think has Workshop
models as well uh but that has a minimum
Runway of way less than 2,000 and it's
more of a regional plane so so basically
uh what all of this means is that we
have a somewhat small runway in the city
but it's good enough to land some
International planes and we can also
have some Regional traffic so this can
actually be albe it a small one this can
actually be an international Hub and
also be another Hub within Bahrain like
if you wanted to go from the north side
of the country which is the the part of
the country which is very heavily
populated and where the big cities are
if you want to go from there to Amar
City you could practically do that with
the airports and um you know this is
just a handy thing to have if you have
that kind of service economy and you've
got like business people and stuff like
that who want to get to other places
very quickly you should be like at the
airport in in Omar City in under 15
minutes from wherever you are in the
city and that's just a pretty handy
thing to have
economically so yeah while we have that
going on I wanted to go back and do a
lot of the detailing around the highway
it's not nearly enough time to actually
get all of it done since I wanted to
mess quite a bit with foliage and decals
but one of the things which already kind
of chipped away at there is the road
works by putting in some decorations
around parking lots and roundout to make
that all a little bit more fancy and I
also wanted to experiment a little bit
with uh some of the decals now these are
some of the the newest decals and um
what I really like about these is these
are the theme decals and massive uh
thanks to Ron x69 by the way for making
this mod because it's it's amazing and
it's super helpful but the great thing
about it is that these decals in my case
given the theme are very subtle like the
differences between them aren't too
Stark and what I found with a lot of the
earlier like standard sort of ground
texture decals is that they're all meant
for different uh biomes than what Omar
city is made in like a lot of the decals
that you'll find around the lot of the
assets in the game in general are just
built for
uh sort of northern European uh or North
American European kind of climates and
don't really work too well with the
light bright s textures that I have
going on but the theme uh decals
actually work really well and they sort
of give that very subtle difference in
Scent textures and uh like some some
small parts with pebbles like basically
it gives you some different textures to
look at it makes uh the ground look bit
more believable realistic and
interesting to look at without making it
very busy on the eye and a mess of all
kinds of different textures so I was
really happy to mess around with those
different uh theme decals and put some
very simple foliage on top of that to
preserve the very desert look while at
the same time making it not too boring
to look at now on the other side of the
road I wanted to get to the short-term
parking right here and also the taxi
stands and also a little bit of the
detailing of the industrial area around
here we've got like a small little Park
path going between the industrial area
and the terminal in here uh which is not
too necessary or too goodlooking but
something that I just figured I could
put in between those and um a lot of the
detailing around the parking lots is
just making it look like a believable
parking lot so getting some of these
lights in between there some planters to
Spruce it all up a little bit and uh
some interesting decals as well for the
paths by King loo a massive thanks to
him as well like I don't think I can
shout him out enough uh especially for
making the fill at Armor city which is
an amazing asset but in general you know
series like this wouldn't be possible
without the the mod creators and the
asset creators but anyway um I can do
that for hours um I just wanted to put
some simple trees in there to shut it
off a little bit from the highway and
then move into the final part of it
which is going to run in front of the
terminal and right in front of the
terminal kind of symmetrically I did
want to have a very small more Park Side
section so you do at least have that
nice little uh separate section I guess
before the terminal so at least it's a
little bit fancy I was first considering
kind of making a bit of a small
Boulevard in front of the terminal
entrance but you know this is this is
the Bahrain climate there is no need for
any like that like it just wouldn't
really work it's not something where
you'd want to sit anyway so um the way
that this is uh designed is just to be a
a pretty Pleasant kind of parking lot
area that isn't just an empty field of
tarmac uh but it's actually quite nice
to look at but that aside it's not
really any kind of place where you
really purposely want to stay so it's
it's pretty much built like that as
well and I also wanted to put all of the
decals in for that same reason because
we do have that large sort of boring
concrete look going for it otherwise
which is not something that I'm a huge
fan of so all of these different um
Stone path decals at least help make
this entire build look a little bit more
interesting than that and I wanted to
border that by adding this other decal
which is a little bit darker and at
first I was not too sure if I should
actually use these decals because they
really are a lot darker than the decals
which I've been using so far uh but they
do actually work quite well together so
I just kind of put that around it to
give it a bit of a border but also give
it an area where it just looks perfectly
for all of the planters that I'm going
to be putting there in the
future now here I derped out because I
didn't really have any decals to make a
a Crossing with so I'm pretty much
procrastinating on that until I found
until I find something good that I can
make that Crossing with but until that
day it's just empty for the time being
which hopefully isn't too bad and and um
I'm fencing it all off with a simple
glass fence and putting a bit of
decoration over here to at least make it
look like a little bit of a park and
also get that sort of symmetrical
interaction with the building itself in
as well and hopefully and this is pretty
important in this climate as well uh
provide some shade so you can at least
somewhat walk in the shade uh while
you're going to the terminal from
whatever shortterm or uh text stand uh
you're coming
from this is something that I do want to
consider quite a lot uh because the
amount of foliage that I place in the
city is definitely not as sustainable as
much as I like to Proclaim that the city
is sustainable but I think it's just way
too crucial to have some foliage in the
city for shade reasons partly but also
just because it makes it look better and
because they filter the air it's just
too important to have these trees around
to not have them just for the s reason
that you know it would be slightly
better considering what it
costs besides something interesting that
I still want to try is to try and put
some permaculture out there in the
desert and try to get some more foliage
back in there because interestingly
bakarin isn't a complete baren Wasteland
uh it definitely does have some foliage
especially around the West Coast if I'm
not mistaken and it's just really
historically relied quite a lot on
freshwater reserves that are underground
and those have been just generally
filling up with more salts in recent
years and that's a huge issue but that
aside it would actually be a really
interesting project to see how you could
actually fill the desert with more
foliage and sort of reforest it in a
similar way that many projects are
trying to around the area but that's
something for a later day for now a lot
of the foliage around here is to just
make this area come to life a little bit
more and also hopefully hold on to the
sand a little bit because obviously I do
want want to maintain the idea that uh
this is some more slightly more core
scent that's actually being held down by
some foliage and not just flying around
and whipping us whipping up storms all
the time because that's definitely not
something I want to have either this
grass by the way is super weird in a
sense that it kept floating so I had to
like drag it down with move it all the
time and also it's literally floating in
a sense that it kind of moves as if it's
on the water and in real time you don't
really see it too much in fact it
actually kind of looks as if the the
grass is waving a little bit in the wind
uh but actually that's the the Primal
reason why it's it's floating because
it's this is like a large open stretch
Overland and the game things that the
trees so that makes them wave because
this is a very windy area but anyway uh
it kind of looks as if it's windy in
real time but in the time lapse it's
definitely a little bit
ridiculous but yeah there's not much I
can do about that because yeah uh
in-game mechanics if you've got like a
large open stretch of land and there's
going to be a lot of wind the game
thinks that your grass are trees and
it's just going to move those trees as
if they're trees but it's actually grass
so that's kind of something that's a
little bit annoying anyway here I wanted
to start work a little bit on the
industrial complex on the left side of
the airport definitely not enough time
to finish this entire thing because this
this episode is already becoming very
long and that is including some parts
that I left left out of the time lapse
and including a lot of like preparation
that I left out as well it just takes a
while to get all of this done in the way
that I'm hoping to uh but yeah at least
I can get some of these industrial
complexes in here and get a very good
start on the
airport and get a pretty good idea of
what this is going to look like
eventually I hope to finish this by the
way in the next episode at least I hope
to finish the airport itself in the next
episode the direct area around here is
most definitely not going to be finished
and the same kind of goes for the
highway I kind of want to have a
separate Highway episode as well um but
for now I'm quite happy with the
progress that I do have in this episode
I really just wanted to to wrap it up
over here uh because this gives a good
idea of what the general layout of the
episode is or of the airport is going to
be and how I'll be detailing some of
these points as well and so in the next
episode we'll be getting into some
further detailing actually getting some
planes in the airports actually putting
all sorts of stuff around that giving
the industrial areas some detail and a
grittier look to it and also doing a bit
of basic detailing around the highway
basically making sure that this entire
area is finished because right now it's
very much done in terms of overall
layouts and the general idea that I
wanted to get to but it just still needs
that flare of detail here and there but
yeah that's basically it for this
episode so thank you guys for watching
and I hope to see you guys in the next
[Music]
one
[Applause]
[Music]